Speaker 1: All right, welcome, everybody, let's
get started after a long holiday weekend in the
United States federal holiday. We were off with
the latest COVID news. It's it's really pretty
good. In five states, the COVID situation is
getting worse in 45 plus D.C. it's getting
significantly better to the point where cases
in the United States have now plummeted by
about 50 percent since their Delta Peak. So all
good news. Vaccine doses are up a little bit.
Cases are down. Deaths are now down. And
the question is becoming what happens in the
winter season. So let's start at the very
beginning how our cases looking globally.
Globally, cases are down from their delta
peak of about 660000 a day, an insane number
down to about 400000 a day, 440000 a day.
That's a decline of nearly 39 percent now
in the United States. Cases are down even
more precipitously. If you believe the data,
which I think we've talked about this before. Big
picture we mostly can, even if we're not getting
the full story from every single state.
Cases in the U.S., down from their delta
peak of about 160 7000 to about 85000 cases a
day, still a ton of cases, but it's a decline
of it's about 50 percent, forty nine point
something percent. Now, the caveat here is
do those numbers include what is obviously slower
reporting thanks to the long holiday weekend,
these numbers might end up being adjusted up a
little bit as the testing and reporting kind of
catches up and is integrated into these numbers.
But big picture a significant decline at this
point in terms of deaths, which often follow
cases by three to four weeks. Globally, deaths
are down about 34 percent from their Delta Peak,
which remember, it's not the full pandemic peak.
OK. The Delta Global Death Peak was about 10000
deaths a day. At one point we were at 14000 in a
previous peak. So down from about 10000 a day to
like 60 750 within the United States. The death
decline is not quite as sharp. Deaths in the US,
down about 26 percent from their Delta peak, now
around 14 500 per day. Remember this relevant
data point when we want to think about just how
are we doing in general? In a normal flu season
in the U.S., there's about 100 deaths a day.
Again, they're not really 100 a day there.
They're concentrated during flu season, you've
got more than 100 a day during flu season, fewer
than 100 a day in the summer, but by 100 a day.
COVID, of course, is still way, way higher than
that multiples higher in terms of vaccination. We
are seeing daily vaccine doses trickle up a little
bit. Remember that daily vaccinations at one point
had surpassed three million new doses per day
in the U.S. that was in mid-April. That has come
all the way down at one point down to 500000 new
doses a day. Pathetic number, completely pathetic.
And then, as the Delta variant started to surge,
so did vaccination. As Joe Biden announced some
vaccine requirements, there was another surge in
vaccination, and recently we've seen daily doses
administered in the U.S. up to about a million a
day. We could be doing so much better. We have so
many doses available, but you still prefer to see
one million per day rather than 500000 globally.
New doses are also up. You might remember last
week I said, Hey, guys, we're seeing 23 million
doses a day. We're up to 25 million doses a day
globally. These are still really small numbers,
but I'll mention them. Last week we were seeing
zero point two nine percent of the population
getting a dose. That's up to now zero point three
two percent of the global population is getting a
dose each day. These are tiny, tiny numbers, but
it's an increase and we'll take any increase that
we can get now compared to the vaccination rate
of any other planet in our solar system. We're
doing really well. We're really kicking some ass.
If we compare Earth to other planets, where do
we go from here? Not really clear. We've not yet
won. I saw a funny article which said Fauci says
we shouldn't declare victory prematurely. I was
thinking we shouldn't declare victory prematurely
again because we already did. I mean, some
places never conceded there was even a battle,
but there were some premature declarations of
victory as well beyond. Beyond that, we've got to
see what happens in terms of the winter. There
is the view that coinciding with flu season,
we're going to see another Coke, another COVID
peak. If we're going to see that, we would expect
to see the numbers turn around relatively quickly
as we're starting to get into the cold season.
In much of the much of the country in terms
of those who say we're not going to see it,
they are saying no, no, no because of vaccination
and because of everything that's going on.
This is now completely sort of like unlinked from
the seasonality of flu season. We're not going to
see a winter spike remains to be seen in about six
weeks. We're going to know. But in the interim,
let's hope things continue
going in the right direction.